welcome ghosts and ghouls back to
October top 5 I'm Walter benezia I'm
Heather Ruth and I'm a no Wayne even the
most iconic of series are bombed to go
through their rough patches this can be
especially true when dealing with the
supernatural on a television budget
monsters of the week can turn into
nightmares whether the plot is too
boring out there or just a bit dated I'm
glad that you're back to normal here
Ayana no crazy conspiracy walls or
Walter 2.0 dressed in costumes oh yeah
maybe just don't go in the makeup room
then why well I find if I go in there
nothing it's just that all of the walls
are covered in research just tell me
that stupid dummy still isn't in there I
needed a partner okay do you have any
idea what it's like watching all of
those episodes yes yes we do it's a part
of our jobs oh right well these are the
top five worst x-files episodes number
five bad luck hey you know what would
you do for x-files know anything oh yeah
even overlook the infamous but Genie
episode well I would do anything for
x-files but I won't do that in Indian
burger hitches a ride to America through
a man's anus and wreaks havoc and not
just on the guy's butthole seriously
that's the plot this beggar is a fakir
with the ability to cast illusions like
appearing as other individuals or being
in a place when he's actually somewhere
else
the beggar turns into a janitor and
witnesses a young boy that gets bullied
he then decides to kill that kid's dad
when Scully performs the autopsy the man
climbs out of the dad's body and crawls
away
this is also a Doggett episode so Scully
try seeing this case how Mulder would
have the whole time this leads to her
making some wildly out of character
theories I really tried to take this
episode seriously the squeaking of the
cart is ominous at least but the
xenophobia aside what even was the
motive here the killings aren't random
enough to be spree killings and if this
is supposedly revenge for being a beggar
the people he targets
the good guys like a dad stopping a
bully or mom trying to save her drowning
son the gross horror is far from boring
but not enough to carry an entire
episode this episode didn't make sense
it did
in some wait no it didn't Scully
number four Babylon haven't you always
wanted to see a cowboy Mulder on a drug
trip no well too bad when suicide
bombers attack an art gallery agents
Miller and Einstein must find a way to
communicate with the comatose terrorists
they enlist the help of Scully and
Mulder to try and stop the terrorist
cells next attack
agent Miller is a young man who believes
in the conspiracies while agent Einstein
is a redheaded medical doctor who has a
healthy dose of skepticism and you see
where I'm going with this right yeah
they really pushed this younger Scully
and Mulder narrative ad nauseam
Mulder ends up joining forces with
Einstein behind Scully's back to follow
a whim
while Scully traces a lead with Millard
this splits up the main door for most of
the episode and replaces them with their
younger counterparts
Mulder takes mushrooms under the medical
supervision of Einstein and has this
insane premon Ettore hallucination
we later learned that Einstein had given
Mulder a placebo but can't explain how
Mulder had a vision telling him the
actual location of the other Bombers
this could have been an opportunity to
look past race I was half hoping they
would prove the brothers at the
beginning were actually innocent and
they were being racially profiled but
the story stay two-dimensional by
relying on stereotypes and leaning
heavily on coincidences this was an
episode meant to parallel Scully and
moulders first meeting and show how far
they've come what it accomplished was
showing the newer seasons were just as
guilty as the old ones at cliched and
lazy writing number three Fight Club
what would you do if you knew there was
a perfect copy of yourself out there in
the world following your every move
Heather that literally happened to us do
you not remember the duplicates or the
Dinah Rob dimension yeah don't you have
a twin sister too well excuse me I was
just trying to create a mood this
episode is about Betty Templeton and
Lulu Pfeiffer doppelgangers that cause
people to explode in anger these women
keep moving to avoid each other but are
drawn to the same places and activities
they are also in love with the same man
Bert zupanic a wrestler trying to have
his last hurrah this episode guest stars
Kathy Griffin as both Betty and Loulou
all of the acting in this episode is
turned up to a weird level and Griffin
is hardly the only offender you know
what they say everyone has a twin out
there somewhere no we don't know what
they say Betty and Loulou are grating
and don't have much Drive besides trying
to avoid the other one their powers are
also inconsistent sometimes people fight
when they're in the same room sometimes
it's in the same town and molder gets
sucked into the sewer at one point for
some reason they even destroy the same
bar twice like a day apart and this is
never explained there was definitely
room to make a joke there but no the
soundtrack is incredibly distracting
throughout the episode as well I know
father
Yankee Doodle into a plastic
when we find out zupanic has a twin as
well everyone stops fighting so I was
excited to see the opposite of the women
like peace doppelgangers and Betty and
Lulu could live happily with the man
they were both drawn to but nope they
caused even more mayhem so I don't even
know why people stopped fighting there
isn't even an end the sets of doubles
are just left out in the world to
hopefully not cause accidents anymore I
enjoy the concept of having two people
causing bad things to happen when in
close proximity especially in the
wrestling match scenario but the
execution left plenty to be desired
number two space hey want to see the
face of Mars possess an astronaut and
mess with stuff no really
a sabotage shuttle launch brings Scully
and Mulder to investigate an inside
source at NASA
unfortunately the commanding officer is
hiding something from the crew he's
possessed by an alien ghost supposedly
it would have been living inside Colonel
belt for years after hitching a ride
back from his last Gemini flight Colonel
belt seems to want the shuttle launched
work but it's unclear what exactly this
space Spirit wants a malfunctioning
engine part would mean the crew wouldn't
arrive home safely if more ghosties
wanted to come to earth are there more
did the one just want to go back home
then why didn't he go on to the shuttle
and if it wanted to kill the humans in
space that's like single digits why
strain them in space and not kill them
on earth why bother
oh and Scully just watches a being come
out of a person and remains a skeptic
there are plenty of other gaping plot
holes throughout for a script that is
convoluted and boring the forced
suspense doesn't work as the ghost is
silly
rather than menacing and the special
effects were not good even for when it
first aired using stock footage from
NASA was supposed to make this episode
be low-budget but it ended up being the
first season's most expensive episode to
make as it is in the first season when
most shows are still finding their
footing we can't quite award it as the
worst
and the number one worst x-files episode
is peso dos bichos dislikes by cast crew
and viewers alike this episode really
did its best to never come to light at
the excavation of a South American
burial urn native workers disagreed with
the removal of this religious artifact
the Cavalier archeologist is then killed
by a Jaguars spirit when the urn is
brought to the Boston Museum of Natural
History more deaths occur but people
think it's due to extreme protesters
there's a red herring with the assistant
archaeologist dr. Balak being the killer
under the influence of a hallucinogen
we're also led to believe it's a Jaguar
spirit responsible for the death but
also street cats the Hokie curse remains
trope is tired and the
monster-of-the-week is hilariously bad
the production of this episode was
fraught with complications
it went through constant rewrites and
they had some trouble with their animal
actors when placed on set the crew tried
to get the cats to look menacing on
camera but they could only look cute and
sweet the cats also wouldn't attack on
command or even move when asked the
trainer's tried spraying them with water
and even chasing them with dogs to make
matters worse Gillian Anderson is
allergic to cats so they had to build a
cat puppet to attack her with but even
that they had a hard time making looks
serious perhaps my favorite bit of
trivia is that the episode title
translates to animal burial mound but be
chose has an alternate translation
testicles an apt title either way we
want to hear what you guys think what's
your least favorite x-files episode what
do you want to see us cover next on the
show leave a comment and let us know to
keep in touch you could like my Facebook
page or follow along on Twitter and you
can find me on Facebook Twitter
Instagram or subscribe to my animated
movie review series right here on
YouTube and you can find me on Twitter
Instagram or Twitter I stream on
Wednesday nights well catch it back here
next week with a special Simpsons
Halloween countdown
you